[Music]
look Anderson was game to go behind the
scenes of tag John has been seeing
Entertainment Tonight in the green moon
can 300 since you guys arrived we're
always there for you John and we learned
that on this set the stars are always
cracking each other up the movie is
about longtime friends who get super
intense playing a month-long game of tag
I'm going to be the one who tags Jerry
we're going full-bore
but yeah it's a it's really fun it's a
great group of guys trying to tag the
next one in is good Oh God
I would go home after days like this
where were litters sprinting around
jumping around 46 years old like I don't
bout that like this guy bounces back
when it's edited together in slow motion
John and Jeremy Renner showdown kinda
seems like a matrix movie callahan
approaches from the left engage new a
contact protocol Jeremy got so physical
doing his scenes he fractured both his
arms stunt rigging broke and I broke one
with it crazy freak you know accident ah
he's a superhero I was like if I get a
hangnail I'm going home for a week it is
amazing that Jeremy kept shooting
[Music]